il est désormais possible de se tester
au kovy 19 à la maison vendue pour
quelques euros en pharmacie depuis cette
semaine les autotests vient de compléter
l'arsenal sanitaire rapide moins
contraignants et surtout plus discret
attention il faut néanmoins suivre le
mode d'emploi avec précaution et en cas
de résultat positif il est fortement
conseillé de faire en plus un test pcr
explications de paul boyer donc on voir
sur 20 on en a vendu 3 depuis hier à la
pharmacie mutualiste de tours-nord des
autotests qu'ovide sont en vente depuis
lundi à 6 euros l'unité ces tests sont
vendus par boîte de 5 alors prendre la
boîte vous avez 4 chose dont j'avais un
petit flacon comme sade réactif vous
avez coché dans laquelle vous avez un
écouvillon une claque de migration est
un petit bouchon en fait le principe est
simple se tester soi même chez soi à
l'aide d'un écouvillon l'antre sur 2 3
cm une fois que ces rentrées dans la
cloison d'un vallon la baisse de
quelques degrés pour ressentir une sorte
de distance une fois la distance à
tecteo souvent légèrement 3,4 cours au
niveau de la plaza attendait 15 minutes
puis vous aurez le résultat chez vous
une barre vous est négatif de barbouzes
est positif mais attention si ces autos
tests sont faciles à utiliser
il est recommandé d'aller faire un test
pcr en laboratoire en cas de positivité
recommandations de la dgse que nous
recevons en fait régulièrement
valide pas en fait le test aujourd'hui
il reste que le rt pcr ou le test en
technique qui permet en fait le
déplacement à l'étranger
du côté des patients l'arrivée des
autotests est une bonne nouvelle cela
leur permettra d'éviter d'aller en
laboratoire au moindre symptôme aller
dans les laboratoires pour faire la
queue déjà droite à gauche et jusque là
on vient on l'achète et puis on fait la
maison corps j'ai eu une bonne chose que
celui d'aller dans les laboratoires ça
on fait confiance à son pharmacien ou
prend le produit qu'il faut et surtout
c'est assez rapide surtout ça longtemps
attendu ces autos tests feront leurs
preuves si le geste est correctement
exécuté mais n'ayez crainte
votre pharmacien vous fournira un mode
d'emploi que vous pourrez appliquer à la
maison